[Müzik]
Evet 3 yaşındayım İstanbul Bostancı'daki
evimizde odamdayım Herkesin bir hayali
arkadaşı vardır O zamanlar benimkiler de
Kınar
pındıcak ü arkadaşım kar Pınar ve sar o
gün ü Küçük çocuğum benim Üstelik ilk
defa okula Baş AC akları için çok
heyecanlılar E ben de anneleri olarak
çok heyecanlıyım Elime aldığım hayali
bir kamerayla fotoğraflarını çekiyorum
ekrana bakıyorum beğenmiyorum tekrar
çekiyorum yıl
1984 Tabii 3 yaşındayım bu kadar net
hatırlamıyorum ama annem babam sağ olsun
Anılar konusunda bayağı titizler
70'lerin sonunda aldıkları bir kamerayla
bu ve birçok hanımı kayıt altına
almışlar Sonrasında da Almanya'ya
gönderip banyolu atıp filme çevirmişler
Biz de beyaz perdede izleme şansı bulduk
bu videoları ve bu videoları izlediğimde
anladım ki aslında hayat bana bir ipucu
veriyormuş Hayal oyunlarının
sınırsızlığın keşfettiğin teknolojiyle
bağını daha o günlerde kurmuştum Özlem
der gibi zaman geçti ben büyüdüm kınd
arla
pındiy girdiler evlendiler çocuk sahibi
oldular Hayat bazen bizi farklı yollara
götürdü bir birden uzaklaştık sonra
tekrar Hayal dünyamızda buluştuk
birbirimize yaşadıklarımızı anlattık
hayallerimizden bahsettik Kınar hayalimi
anlattığımda kahkahayla güldü Bana
bayağı bozuldum Aslında utandım kar ise
aksine çok destekledi çok teşvik etti
beni sındır ise sorguladı sordu da sordu
ta ki tatmin olana kadar bazen tatmin
olmadı da ama ne ben onlara hayallerim
bahsetmekten Vazgeçtim ne de büyük
hayallerimden Hayal oyunlarım aslında
Bir yetişkin olarak bile Hiçbir zaman
vazgeçmedim Hatta bugün burada ilk defa
yüksek sesle İtiraf ediyorum ki ben
içimdeki çocuğu ve hayal arkadaşlarımı
hiç
öldürmedim yaşadıklarım ve
yaşantılarımız la anılan geniş ailemin
ilk torunuyum farklı nedenlerden de olsa
sanki ailemin genlerinde Eee koşulları
zorlayan mevcut koşullarda durmayan eee
bir gen vardı Ah o geni Bir Bulsam bu
gen meydan okuyan bu gen yüzünden 5
yaşındayken klasik çocuk sorgulamalarına
Amerikan Koleji'nde okuyacağım boziç
Üniversitesi'ne gideceğim diye cevap
verirdim Tabii bu sor sorgulama
Karşısında beni bozmamak için insanlar
sadece gülümserler mii çok iddialı
bulurlar mış Cevabımı 5 yaşında olduğum
için kında gibi bozmazlar mış beni ama
ben onların elinde olan o kısıtlı veri
setine erişimim yoktu mesela babamın
Doktor olması nedeniyle bir ik yıl
içerisinde mecbur hizmet için başka bir
ile taşınmak zorunda olacağımızı
bilmiyordum Nitekim 7 yaşında
Kastamonu'ya
taşındığımızda ve hayallerimin su
düştüğünü sananlar 12 yaşında Amerikan
kolleji gitmek için ailemi Kastamonu'da
bırakıp Hayatımda ilk defa Okulun ilk
günü ayak bastığım İzmir'e yerleşeceğim
ve bu sefer fındar kazanacağını
bilmiyorlardı
Yıl
1999 bu sefer sıra sındırın tabii Hani
Boğaziçi'ne gidecektin diye dalga geçen
kıara rağmen sarın bir sorusu çok içimi
kemiriyor sanki şurada bir şey daha O
sorunun cevabını bilmiyorsun Özlem
diyordu Üstelik o sene ilk defa açılacak
olan Sabancı Üniversitesi'ni üniversite
sınavında derece yaptığım için Sakıp
Sabancı tarafından bizzat çağrılı oldum
bu beni çok etkilemişti Düşünsenize Daha
18 yaşındasınız
azmiyle doğallığıyla başarılarıyla
otantik liderliğiyle çok ilham aldığınız
birisine bir telefon uzaklık ve fark
ediliyorsunuz daha da önemlisi sındırın
o sorusuna okurken cevap bulma fırsatım
olacaktı Çünkü sadece Sabancı
Üniversitesi'nde ilk ik sene bölümünü
seçmeme özgürlüğü vardı Nitekim ben de
endüstri mühendisliği okurum diye
girdiğim üniversitemden mikroelektronik
mühendisliği üzerine Telekom
Mühendisliği Yüksek lisansı okuyarak
mezun oldum ve anladım ki aslında hayat
ve hayal iç içe ve hayallerimizi
gerçekleştirmek için sadece durup bir
bakmalıyız
geriye kik gard çok sevdiğim bir sözü
vardır hayat geriye doğru anlaşılır ama
ileriye doğru yaşanır diye İşte ben de
şimdi anladım ki 3 yaşındayken o
zamanlarki anaçlı dişiliğin anaçlı İy la
hayali çocuklarıma ürettiğim hayali O
çok ileri teknoloji ürünlerle
üniversitedeyken daha henüz doğmamış
çocukların ileride kullanacakları
bilgisayarların veri işleme hızını
arttıran hızlandıran çip tasarlam ve o
çipi sunmak için tek başıma Japonya'ya
gidip it konferansında sunmam birbirine
çok
bağlıydı İkisinde de yaptığım Aslında
hayallerimle hayatımı
buluşturmaktadır
toplayın uç uca yerleştirin ve hikayeni
içine bir oturtun ve bakın görün Aslında
hayallerinizi gerçekleştirmek için ne
kadar Yetkin ve yeterli olduğunuzu görün
yıllar sonra eee şunu anladım Aslında
Hayat neye nasıl baktığınla ilgili Ben
de bugün burada sizlerle birlikteyken
bir hayalimi gerçekleştirmek
istiyorum tüm dünyadaki kız
çocuklarına ve benim gibi baz kendini
yetersiz hissettiren kınd gibi hayali
arkadaşları olan kız kardeşlerime avazım
çıktığı kadar bağırıp yaparsın demek
istiyorum yaparsınız kız
kardeşlerim Tıpkı ilham aldığım Grace
hopper gibi Grace hopperin hikayesini
incelediğimde biliyorsunuz kodlamanın ve
yazılımın kraliçesi olarak bilinir
kendisi Aslında öyle üstün bir ırka
mensup biri olmadığını Bizler gibi biri
olduğunu
anlamıştım meraklı bir çocukluk
yaşamış Hayaller kurmuş Hayallerinin
peşinden koşmuş Asla pes etmemiş
tutkulu ve esprili bir
kadındı ve anlamıştım ki o gün Aslında
ben de sıradan biri olsam da ben de
yapabilirdim A çok etkilemişti bu beni
ve o küçüklüğümden beri çok sevdiğim
hayal oyunlarına bu sefer e Grace hopper
La birlikte çıktığımda anlamıştım
ki bu kadın bana iki şey öğretmişti
birincisi 36 yaşındayken
yaşlısın ve çok zayıfsın diye çok girmek
istediği o ordunun kapısında ü kez kapı
suratına kapatılmasına rağmen o orduya
Bodrum katından girip sadece
bilgisayarların içindeki bugları
değil yargılı beyinler Deek bugları da
temizlemiş matematik dehasıyla
ve tutkuyla bağlı olduğu hayalini
hayatıyla buluşturmuş
İkincisi
ise olaylara yaklaşım
şekli matematik problemlerini çözerken
esprili bakış açısı Gerçekten beni çok
etkilemişti ben de seçtiğim bu
yolda benzer bir şekilde yol alabilirdim
Mesela ben de geliştirdiğim ürünlerde
servislerde teknoloji dilini ihtiyaç
diline çevirmeyi ve teknolojiyi doğru
noktada doğru yerde buluşturmayı
hedefleyin ve bunları yaparken de
içimdeki çocuğu öldürmeden eğlenerek
çalışabilirim öyle de yaptım 20 yıl
aşkındır ki kariyer hayatımda işte
içimdeki çocukla çıktığımız yollarda
karanlıkta kalıp korksak da Eee yolumuzu
kaybedip sanıp Urup ağlasak da hatta
çelme takılıp tök Öz etil de hep kalktık
ilerledik hatta nasıl düştüğümüz değil
de kalkarken nasıl güldüğümüze
odaklandık Çünkü Bir hayalim vardı ve
yolculuk devam ediyordu kırıntıları
toplayarak cebime ilerlemeye devam ettim
her kırıntı hikayeme bambaşka bir şey
kattı sanki benden daha büyük bir
bulmacanın içinde yerleşiyor gibiydi
Bugün de
burada Cumhuriyet imin 100 yılında
Atatürk'ün milli mücadeleyi başlatmak
için çıktığı Samsun'a Ben de benim
atamla birlikte
çıktım Üstelik bu
konuşma davetini gerçekten çok duygusal
geldi şu anda bana Üstelik bu konuşma
davetini 19 Mayıs günü almıştık o gün de
çok ağladık oğlumla beraber oğlumun adı
da Ata Ve üstelik çok Yeni göreve
geldiğim şirketimin tütün hangarlar an
çevrilen ve kadınların teknoloji
ürettiği Arge merkezleri de Samsun'da Ve
üstelik bu kadar önemli bir konuyu
işlediğimiz coğrafyada milattan önce
2000 yıllarında neredeyse tamamı
kadınlardan oluşan Amazon topluluğu
yaşıyordu Bunlar öyle basit bir tesadüf
olamaz Bence bilginin herkese eşit
mesafede olduğu bir dünya vizyonuyla
yola çıkan ödüllü
kadın girişimcinin ortaklığıyla kurulan
ve çok yakın zamanda bildiğiniz gibi
halka arz olan
şirketimde çalışanların yarısından
fazlası kadın ve ben de kadının
kodladığı
teknolojiyi doğru noktada doğru ürünle
en iyi hizmetle son kullanıcıya
ulaştırabilmek hayaliyle buradayım
geleceğe yazdığı manifestosu yla benim
hayalime giden yolda çok önemli bir
kırıntı bırakan Reader da Ben de
hayalimle hayatımı buluşturmanın
heyecanını yaşıyorum ve bu bana bu bana
HY lamarın sözünü hatırlatıyor hedy
lamar mucit ve aktrist olan hedy lamar
demişti ki bugün burada bulunmamız
tesadüf değildir Her birimizin burada
bulmasının bir amacı vardır hedy lamar
güzelliği ve oyunculuğu kadar çok zeki
bir kadındı günümüzdeki cep telefonları
ve kablosuz ağlar teknolojilerin
temelini oluşturan Eee frekans atlama
spektrumunu bulmuştu ve ben de
düşünüyorum ki Belki de bu buluşu
yaparken sadece hayali arkadaşlarla
oyuncu zaten bir oyun oynuyordu ve
hayalleriyle hayatını buluşturma fırsatı
bulmuştu Neden
olmasın ne kadar kurumsal ve bireysel
çevremde bana Amazon kadını deselerdi
Ben inanıyorum ki her kadının içinde
yatan bir Amazon kadını var ve onu
uyandırmak için benim gibi birçok Amazon
kadını arkadaşım ve kız kardeşimle
beraber teknolojide kadın Derneği
yönetim kurulunda kadın Derneği ve Sales
Network gibi
topluluklarda kadınlara eğitim mentorluk
ve istihdam sağlamaya çalışıyoruz ve
aynı zamanda kadın dayanışmasının
önemini vurgulamaya çalışıyoruz ve
böylece eşit temsiliye toplumdaki
gelişim fırsatlarını yaygınlaştırmaya
çalışıyoruz aynısını bu topraklarda
yaşayan benzer bir şekilde zamanında
Amazon kadınları da yapmıştı Onların da
üç benzer özelliği vardı birincisi
Amazon kadınları kadın dayanışmasına
önem veren eşit ve adil bir toplum için
savaşan ve savaşçı ruhları sayesinde
sürekli gelişim ve eğitim açık olan bir
topluluk Bizler de bugün Burada onların
doğduğu büyüdüğü Hayal kurduğu
topraklarda onlardan ilham alarak
ellerimizde mızraklar ve kalkanlar
yerine telefonlar ve tabletlerle daha
adil bir dünya daha fazla bilgi peşinde
koşan ve dayanışma Temelli ekosistemler
yaratmak için
bulunuyoruz havın içinde uyanan Amazon
kadını insanlığı bambaşka bir devreye
getirdi teknolojideki
gelişmeler arkasında yatan birçok kadın
bizi bugünlere getirdi ama bence
teknolojide kadının sayısından çok ne
ürettiği çok önemli bu yüzden benim için
sayılar oranlardan çok o teknolojiyi
yaratan Kadının her birinin dünyayı daha
iyi bir yer yapmak için uğraşları
değerli Yani evet bir kişi Belki bir
oranı değiştiremez Ama tüm dünyadaki bir
şeyi
değiştirebilir her şeyi kadın yapar daha
iyi yapar gibi bir söylem için de asla
değilim Onu belirtmek isterim ama
kapsayıcılığı ve dengenin ancak mevcut
bakış açısını değiştirerek ve söylemleri
eyleme dönüştürerek ve teşvik ederek
mümkün olduğunu düşünüyorum düşünce
zincirlerimiz Deek basma kalıpları
kırmanın tam zamanı kalıp demişken yine
Grace hopper bir örnek vereceğim Grace
der ki en tehlikeli cümle bunu Biz her
zaman böyle yaptık cümlesidir
düşünün I Dünya Savaşı'nda Ordu gibi
Emir Muta zincirinde çalışılan bir yerde
istenmeyen Bir Kadın söylüyor bunu
gerçekten benim için çok değerli bir
cümledir bu ne zaman ki olaylara kendime
başka kişilere farklı açıdan bakmam
gerektiğinde bu cümleyi Hatırlatırım
kendime çünkü İnanırım ki merakın
inovasyona dönüşmesinin sihri burada
yatar Çünkü İnanırım ki doğru sorular
sormak artık devrimiz daha da
önemli bugün insan ve toplum beynindeki
ön yargıları silebilecek
süper bir güce sahip değiliz Belki bir
kere de
silemeyeceği yaratabilecek güce sahibiz
Yani her şey nereye nasıl ne kadar
baktığımız la alakalı Yani her şey
aslında hayatı verdiklerimize
aldıklarımız gibi yani rilkenin dediği
gibi kalpten söylenen Kalbe akıldan
söylenen akla
gidermiş a lovas tarihe adını ilk kadın
Bilgisayar ilk bilgisayar programcısı
olarak yazdırdı Üstelik bir kadındı ve
bir konuşmasında şöyle
demişti gelecek
nesiller Analitik motorların sadece
matematik işlemleri yapmasını değil
müziği ifade etmesini sanat üretmesini
beklemelidir
ve bundan 175 yıl sonra insansı Rob
Sofya Jimmy fonla düet yaptığında sanki
a lovın kalbinden çıkan söz yıllar sonra
başka birisine ilham olmuştu ve onun
hayalini hayatıyla buluşturmuş
bugün Sofya amca Aida gibi insansız
robotların üzerinde çalışan ve aid lowan
ilham alan birçok kadın var ve
gelecekte robotların ne yapacağı değil
onları üretenlerin ne yapacağı asıl
önemli olan
a Lov hedy lamar Grace hopper Bunlar
teknolojiye yön veren birçok Amazon
kadınından birkaç tanesi bu bu hikayeler
Aslında kadının teknolojide üretici
olduğunu ve birbirlerinden zaman
bağımsız bir şekilde bağlı olduğunu
gösteren simgesel
hikayeler Rönesans sonrası aydınlanmaya
başlayan insanlığın üst bilgi ırkına
doğru yolculuğunda teknolojide kadının
üretici olmadığı bir dünya düşünülemez
o zaman nereye gideceğimiz belli Aslında
nereden geldiğimize bakmalı geçmiş
hayallerimize
bakmalı Hayal kurmaya devam etmeli ve
benim bugün fırsat bulduğum gibi
hayallerimizi yüksek sesle
anlatmalıyız Çünkü kime ilham olacağı ve
o kişinin dünyayı nasıl
güzelleştireceğim bilemeyiz bugün bana
Hayal arkadaşlığı yaptığınız için çok
teşekkür ederim Unutmadan bir
de ve sındırın size selam